I HOPE YOU'LL GIVE US A PASS ON
TRYING TO THINK THAT THROUGH IN
>> Tucker: THANKS, CAESAR.
>> THANKS.
>> Tucker: ANDREW CLAVEN IS FROM
CITY JOURNAL.
HE WROTE A PIECE IN RESPONSE TO
THE PRESIDENT'S IMMIGRATION
REMARKS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO READ THE
FIRST LINE OF THIS.
NOTHING SCANDALIZES A LEFTIST
LIKE THE TRUTH.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> THE LEFT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
OF MAKING THE STATEMENT OF
SIMPLE FACTS SEEM RUDE AND EVIL
AND UNKIND.
PATHS, IF YOU SAY THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS COMMIT
DISPROPORTIONATE ABOUT OF
VIOLENT CRIMES, IF YOU SAY THAT
MUSLIMS COMMIT A
DISPROPORTIONATE ABOUT OF
TERRORISM, THEY REAR BACK AND
CALL YOU A BIGOT.
THEY SAY YOU'RE RACIST OR SEXIST
OR WHATEVER UNTIL THINGS THAT
ARE FACTUALLY TRUE ARE
UNEXPRESSABLE.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY THIS.
I DON'T THINK CONSERVATIVES
FULLY APPRECIATE THE POWER OF
THAT MENTAL SLAVERY.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE WAY IT
WRAPS AROUND YOUR MIND AND KEEPS
YOU OF SAYING THE THINGS YOU'RE
THINKING.
>> Tucker: SHOULDN'T ALL
AMERICAN CITIZENS REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL PARTY OR PHILOSOPHY
DEMAND TO LIVE BY THE STANDARD
THAT WE LIVE BY, WHICH IS TRUTH
AS A DEFENSE?
SHOULDN'T WE STAND BY THAT?
>> YES.
USUALLY YOU KNOW, USED TO BE THE
LOUD MOUTHS AND SAY WHATEVER
COMES TO THEIR HEAD, THAT USED
TO PROTECT US.
THE LEFT HAS BEEN EXCEPTIONALLY
GOOD AT MAKING SURE -- WE
LEARNED LAST WEEK THAT TWITTER
IS SHADOW BANNING CONSERVATIVES.
WE'VE SEEN HOW GOOGLE FIRES A
GUY THAT STATES SOMETHING
TUBE.
AND SPEAKERS AT UNIVERSITIES ARE
MET WITH VIOLENT RESISTANCE.
THE LEFT IS INTENT ON SILENCING
RIGHT-WING OPINION.
IT'S VERY POWERFUL.
YOU LOOK OVER WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN EUROPE WHERE THEIR
SAY, WELL, MAYBE ISLAM DOESN'T
FIT.
CONSERVATIVE -- 1,400 GIRLS WERE
RAPED BY PAKISTANI MUSLIMS
BECAUSE THE POLICE DIDN'T WANT
TO CALL THEM OUT BECAUSE THEY
WERE AFRAID OF BEING CALLED
RACIST.
ONE OF THE THINGS I SEE WHEN I
LOOK AT DONALD TRUMP -- I'M A
POLITE GUY AND A GUY THAT
DOESN'T LIKE TO OFFEND PEOPLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I SEE
THAT WORKS FOR DONALD TRUMP IS
HIS RUDENESS AND HIS BORISHNESS
HAVE SHATTERED THIS PRISM OF
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS THAT THE
LIFT HAS MANAGED TO CONSTRUCT.
MOUTH AND EVERY TWEET THAT HE
SENDS OUT IS SUCH A SCANDAL.
IF YOU TURN ON CNN OVER THE
WEEKEND AFTER HIS REMARKS ABOUT
WERE CRYING.
IT WAS SO INTOLERABLE TO THEM
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS NOT
RESTRAINED BY THEIR DEFINITION
OF WHAT IS CRUEL AND THEIR
DEFINITION OF WHAT IS IMPOLITE.
THIS IS A NETWORK WHERE ANDERSON
COOPER CALLED ORDINARY
RIGHT-WING AMERICANS, HE CALLED
THEM TEA BAGGERS.
NOW WHEN HAITI IS INSULTED, HIS
LIP IS TREMBLING AND HIS EYES
ARE MISTY.
IT'S A FORM OF BULLYING.
IT'S A FORM OF SOCIAL BULLYING.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR DONALD TRUMP